eh bien le coup de coeur du cinéma les
yeux d'elsa cette semaine c'est la
continuation du festival les yeux peint
des toiles notre septième édition sur le
thème de la science fiction est
particulièrement vendredi soir vendredi
8 juin à partir de 20h15 nous
diffuserons 3 film d'animation
d'animation japonaise traditionnellement
tous les ans d'organismes soirée
animations et cette année c'est donc le
8 juin avec mutafukaz un film réalisé
par un japonais et un français le
français s'appelant guillaume renard le
deuxième film the perfect blue un film
absolument gigantesque un thriller
psychologique formidable réalisé par
satoshi kon et akira un film majeur dans
l'histoire du cinéma d'animation
japonais réalisé par katsuhiro otomo
[Musique]